okay less talking more doing in the
kitchen
okay these kids roll you start with a
store-bought crescent roll you can make
the roll the dough from scratch that's
really easy to just grab it from the
supermarket give it a little tap maybe I
need you to help me open that things
flop out I remember this is something
I've actually made I've made these
before thank you
this is like a very classic childhood
recipe for me and many okay you fill
these little crescent rolls with fun
ingredients I chose sweet ingredients
for myself figuring that you were like a
little bit saltier saltier I like like a
savory yeah you're putting in yours
I'm gonna put Hershey's Kisses in mind
because I'm sort of a classic I have a
classic approach to this Hersey's
Hershey's kiss roll call about the
melted chocolate goo in the center for
me okay for you I brought everything
from maple syrup to peanut butter to
bacon yeah I'm doing these treats these
right here are Frito Lays I'm putting
those on and I'm putting some what is
this right here oh those are some like
cheddar popcorn pop okay just raw
sausages I'm putting on mine as you
can't have left sausage get crazy here
all right I just made mine just looks
like an accident you're not happy to
mine we take your crescent rolls you
roll them up to keep all those fun
ingredients inside and then you pop them
into a bundt pan I love you trying to
roll up mine that's not oh I mean I
guess we kind of were searching it up in
my kitchen at home okay and then you put
it if you're going savory you could just
show that show that to people that's
what I just made that looks
[Applause]
you pay a surgeon to remove from your
spine it's gonna taste delicious when it
comes out of the oven yeah I promise you
yeah that's I'm gonna use extra dough to
wrap around the sausage right there and
just make that thing right so the beauty
of this is that it's all about
choose-your-own-adventure and from there
you pop it in the oven and what comes
out of lourdes part of the cooking
demonstration go from this piece of crap
right here and then magically it becomes
this which would never happen in a
million yeah that's the beauty of this
recipe and then it becomes this like
really fun pull up out pull apart monkey
bread okay and you just pull that and
then there's all this cool stuff inside
look all of your cheddar popcorns
they're chocolate in this one apparently
yeah okay oh wow so healthy I brought an
even better recipe to hurry up this one
it's called crackle okay which is our
crack pie that we make it milk bar meat
sort of a toffee brittle like state so
we make the crack pie so a crack pie
more people will be interested you can
always explain later on that it's a
misunderstanding
all right you get the melted butter in
here melted butter in all right stop
sassing me all right so you get all
these ingredients together that we make
our crack by selling for but instead of
filling it in a bag we we spread it on a
sheet pan and again it's a sort of
choose-your-own-adventure mentality okay
of what fun ingredients go on this
baking sheet with this crack pie filling
okay let's put these Ritz crackers on
there and let's put this I feel like
you're creating a Noah's Ark landscape
okay
fruity pebbles the greatest cereal ever
in crackle something tells me you'll
respond to this second part of crackle
yeah this gets baked off in the oven and
if your TV magic baked what happens is
you get this amazing crack pie filling
meets brittle and the best part about
this is once it comes out of the oven is
that it needs to be broken apart because
it's brittle by a very strong burly man
with some sort of cleaver or rolling pin
Andy come here Amy
[Applause]
too hard oh you are table look at that
that is incredible okay yeah sort of the
marriage of my two favorite things
travel really good
you